what is that it's my singing mine can I
answer emails while we're doing this
baby baby all right ladies and gentlemen
of your favorite podcast there you go I
always give the guest a second Mike you
got
this is what the singer mics there
anytime you need it of course Rachel
calls right the end of it does good
timing rang you know you have it on like
look at this I love that you got the new
iPhone yeah why why do I like did you
get the new iPhone cuz I gave you [ __ ]
for years for having that [ __ ]
androids trash and you know it's stress
how much better is that phone that an
Android can't be honest you know what
the stupid part is I have a cameras way
better I have super part is I have Mac
everything mm-hmm so I have a Mac
computer I have a Mac laptop I have a
iPad and so I had that Samsung phone cuz
I just I don't know why no why
you do know why well I just the
technology on it was just better it was
easier to use there's a few people that
say that to me but what I don't
understand what is it what's the
difference well it has all that like I
just think that how it interacted with
Google I really liked that what does
that mean what are you doing like the
contacts and everything listen dude I've
had a phone now so now I realize that
there ain't no difference I mean but
it's there's no price difference yeah
they're about the same price now that's
the point is I just think that what
people used to be like iPhones are so
expensive
all those androids are [ __ ] oh yeah
they're really expensive but you know I
didn't know that they were so expensive
because I was a part of this program I
was getting free phones from Sam's like
gloves white gloves I know I was a part
of white glove and they're like and I
was like oh this is cool I'm not gonna
go and then the thing cancelled and I
had to buy a phone and I was like $800
this is what peasants have to pay
regular folk have to do to do it wait
before I even do that ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the podcast my good
friend colleague confidant called on
though the wedge between Bobby Lee and I
[Laughter]
Santino okay so now we could continue
many [ __ ] I am grass I Know Who I am
well you know there's a standing war
that they think that that Dark Knight
came through I love all people yeah
people talk [ __ ] to me on Twitter yeah
they can't don't think we're friends
it's really weird I like it it's funny
to me so it's sometimes I'm like these
people get really legit mad about
[ __ ] and then they and they go and
they go at it yeah they go in about like
you know Bobby and Eric would be better
than and Andrew and Bobby you know
there's a whole like state there's poles
there's like you know that's why I said
if we really want to get each other back
would you just do it together you and me
you know so stupid is he originally
talked about doing that a long time ago
yeah I don't know why we didn't do it
and then next thing you know it's like
now we have to deal with you know this
[ __ ] yeah but well the reason that we
didn't do it is cuz you know you live
two plane flights away from me
this [ __ ] had me driving across
the city to get here if you guys just
cuz you want to live in the hot ass
Valley we have to have your [ __ ] a/c
on those like those I don't know I
caught a flight this morning I had one
of my cars died on the way here I had to
buy a new car and get into you delete
your Dilys okay man whatever okay love
this side I loved living on the west
side of town I like to be the beaches
close it's normally cool sure you're
from over it near here no how was I
lived in like mid wheelchair yeah I was
mid-city you know but I you know that's
like centrally located to all the places
I want to go you comfortable everything
good trying to get comfortable okay well
do what you need to do I'm getting
comfortable in these you know what I
don't got Red Rocket I know these were
sorry
I know these were two for one
no I feel like you stole these from an
officer I'm dying of I was passing an
office building and closing up shop Judy
I'm doing this [ __ ] by myself so it has
to be all ghetto like you know renegade
nobody's helping you and nobody helps me
at all I do everything myself you asked
for some help I know I do but it's like
I don't you know any fans that we know I
know I get resumes in the mail is
freaking ridiculous you know in the
paper mail no yeah in a paper mill they
sent me a resume I have a peel box and I
got a resume immediately yeah but
actually speaking of the peel box I want
to use I gave one of these to Steve Lee
I'm giving one to Andrew is booty wipes
they're not even really a sponsor they
just sent me a box of booty wives did I
have so many of them so yeah they're
sponsoring yeah so I was like this
mantra to keep my blue a better cut us a
check if we're talking about this you
know we don't have to talk about I just
want to give you a box of booty well oh
there oh there
singular thank you so you can take it on
the road oh this is actually very smart
do you you do no I do this right what
booty what I travel with when I do this
shot as shot at the Cottonelle yes I
have those twos when I do
school it's this thing that's what you
keep in your wallet or something look at
this and Griff gave me one that's
already been used he are used 15 of
these [ __ ] got something from
lush you know lucious says here's a
small gift for chillin with Griffin time
I include a small clear box you could
put bath bombs in because I was in the I
was doing a Instagram live from the
bathtub when I was on the road I love
taking baths sorry
you know baths in hotels this was a
fancy ho this was the [ __ ] Four
Seasons Meridian that in in Boston man
I still don't take him in not in hotels
this was it fit me though you know I
mean you get a little tub it was a big
tub you know I can't fit I'm six one
with the fire I don't fit in the hotel
tubs I guess I'm saying this one that's
why and it was a lush across the street
so I talked about it then they sent me
let me see
the bath bombs they sent me bath bombs
in a little travel bath bomb thing so
let me see ya look at ya so I just
wanted to like do it on air you know I
can't I don't [ __ ] with this stuff oh I
love it
what if it just makes it smell different
no it's that shit's got like it has like
essential oils in there and bath salts
is good for you know circulation and and
make sure you know muscles less sore you
make sense you're making this up
I'm not you don't know what's in this
[ __ ] what's in this I don't know
what's in that particular one but these
are you go in there and you ask them and
you don't tell you like you say hey my
muscles are sore now go oh you need this
one you know I mean that sounds like
some placebo nonsense what the see bones
work okay so you want to take that away
from me yeah feel good yeah supposed to
feel like me monster you know what I'm
sick of dude me I'm so tired of people
walking up to me regularly now and being
like hey when's I'm dying up here coming
back to you I honestly ya know people do
say to me and I always say I say it's
supposed to be spring of 25 oh you're a
[ __ ]
I love no I'm [ __ ] them I'm even
worse because I'll say like the fact
that you're asking me is why we got
cancelled you're meaner than me
mine's a joke yours is laced in reality
Eric has always been so mad that we got
[ __ ] canceled he would talk about it
on stage yeah Eric would bring me up on
stage at the store and go his necks guys
when I'm my best friend's I love this
dude yadda yadda yadda and then he'd be
like we were on a show together which
got cancelled because you didn't [ __ ]
watch it no alienating the crowd right
away and they like you know thanks for
not watching our show you resented it
had our show got canceled because it had
to be cancelled I why do you say that
cuz it wasn't gonna have any more legs I
don't think there's a go I don't think
the show had a lot more legs I think it
was I think it would have been a great
you know what I really think it would
have been um if it was one fat season of
12 or 15 episodes and then that's it and
that's that's what TV should do nowadays
like American car
I'm Erin at American Horror Story I
don't know even like American Horror
Story what's like every season is
totally different we see this totally
different that's like but like it could
have been like what if it was like the
70s in the comedy world and then every
year we're playing different characters
I was gonna say if it was to give you
70's 80's 90's 22000 but like all these
shows now like stranger things I loved
season 1 season 2 I was like season 3 I
watched two episodes that was out are
you right yeah they're 18 years old
they're not [ __ ] cute little kids
anymore they're grown up dude I hate
when that happens I want to see that
[ __ ] on film and then they kiss and when
they're doing the young love thing young
love is cute when it's real young yeah
but when it's in puberty era it's
repulsive when it's like very creepy
though you know what I mean when it's
the cute little kids your kids cute just
like it's like young playground love and
then when it's like teenage love it's
filth its net nobody wants to see that
especially because they seem like
they're even awkward filming it well
because they are because they're going
through upstate yeah you're watching
them too physically because no one
kisses like yeah so many shows should be
one season stranger things should have
just been one season
I think what I do we just saw something
else that I was like that should have
been [ __ ] one season too what on
Netflix yeah something I can't remember
what I was I just saw somehow with the
second season bum meow it's just
sometimes the first seasons are so
strong you can't do it again so I think
that should be the British TV does it
all the time the BBC will do one or two
seasons and then that's but that's good
yeah but there one or two seasons
there's only three episodes so what so
this or they end up doing like you know
it's like the tenth season of whatever
and this is the 15th
yeah but I think that's smart cuz now
you do TV now TV takes forever to do
takes forever to come out it's arduous
it's long by the time that you've talked
about it and then it comes out I think
the hype is worn away so I think you do
a quick short small and push it right
out fast that's because what the
internet is doing it's killing TV
because the internet is quick you shoot
this you put it out yeah I don't
necessarily like that I like you like
the slow burn yeah
I like to build up I like the
anticipation I like the the feeling of
one after feeling of wanting it to be on
right away
apartment was an appointment appointment
viewing yeah you like that
I like appointment television give me
all of it so I can have you don't like
Game of Thrones you weren't a game of
Thrones guy
no you weren't no I've never seen one
episode well that's why there you go so
you're not you don't you'd never been a
part of that time zero interest if
there's even bet you zero in watching
[ __ ] dragon [ __ ] oh my god mr.
[ __ ] you're so Chicago I hate that
stuff that's that's your muscle that's
your uncle talking right now
fantasy elevation is for [ __ ] Thor
what have you Star Wars no Star Trek
know some Harry Potter no oh yeah a one
oh I know a lot to break that but I want
to like you know do a spell on me you
grown adult male your hobby
don't put that on the podcast tell them
my secrets on Sunday the Lord's Day no
III have hobbies I like working out I
like running I like golf I like I like
um I like snowboarding I like hiking
mountains traveling snowboard it every
year so once a year what do you mean I
got no I got like four or five times a
year
okay are you talking about we I go to
Mammoth I go snowboarding yeah man we
have family in Breckenridge now they
just moved to Park City we're gonna be
going there dude I go I go but see
nobody knows me because in the winter I
disappear yeah I go away I still were in
fact literally after this after this I'm
genuinely going to Val surf to pick up
bertin made these new things this is
lost on you and anybody else who doesn't
care they called step in bindings
they're called step ons uh-huh I'll give
you a quick synopsis for years and years
and years snowboarders have had to sit
down to strap in you know you have to
strap in your bindings and you see
skiers just click click and they get to
just go about 15 years ago the
technology came out that they could do
the same thing with snowboards you can
click in right but it
trash it was track it didn't work people
got unhooked they sucked they broke so
they got thrown away so they went back
to straps people were like [ __ ] it we
have to stay old-school Burton in the
last two years developed the most
advanced technology they've ever done
where you literally click in your boot
and your boot clicks into the the boot
itself clicks into the to the bindings
on the board right and they just made
them in there you know by far the most
wanted thing in the industry I had to
order the [ __ ] in March and I just got
it now so do you like like extreme sport
stuff like that have no it's been a guy
like that no snowboarding is the only
thing that what I would say is a quote
unquote like I mean I grew up
skateboarding when I was a kid but that
was just whatever but is the only thing
I do that's like that I don't motocross
I don't BMX I don't do any of that [ __ ]
I just love the snow I love riding down
a mountain on snow dude you did it one
time if you got used to it let me tell
you something
it's phenomenal all I went skiing one
time I know I can see it in my head
right now okay and it was a nightmare
first of all I got on the skis and they
test you out on like the little kids
were on called a bunny hit the bunny
hill thank you so I'm on the bunny hill
but bro killing it on the bunny hill I'm
like okay so pizza now I'm thinking I'm
the [ __ ] mm-hmm and I make a wrong turn
so I'm supposed to go this way down to
bunny hill you end up at this little
area and I made a right by accident and
I'm going okay
and then the [ __ ] turned into Mount
Everest at a [ __ ] 90 degree and brace
drop just like a straight yeah like a
freefall I felt like the most terrifying
[ __ ] in my life so I had to like oh my
god I'm so terrible I had to ski fall
get up turn ski fall took me it took me
like two and a half hours to get down
the mountain and [ __ ] are
yelling at me they coming out of here
like
everybody's mad at me and then this is
the part that I was done I'm out after
this so when we got down I was like okay
[ __ ] this place they go well if you want
to get back to the lodge you have to go
up to the top of the mountain and see on
the other side yeah so after that
another two three I I wanted to take if
I didn't rent if I had bought the skis
he kills [ __ ] would have been
in the fireplace at the lodge and I'm
just after that I was like I'm out yeah
and I had my cocoa and I was just in the
you know I was answering you like anyway
I'm sticking shipping cocoa you know by
the fire I don't I don't by the way I'm
not scared of it
I think it's childish ass [ __ ] I don't
mess with it so you don't like anything
childish everything have you known me
what do I know everything has to be
grown-up for you it's not grown-up I
just don't like kiddie stuff I don't
like kid stuff
I like kid stuff when I was a kid so you
don't like comic-con you would never go
to comic-con I'll go for a check so you
would I go so you're not gonna be like
you would never be what if they wanted
you to be like you know the Batman is
like Bruce Wayne and is now a redhead
what it is too cuz you've never been
like a superhero that looked like you
was there a super here that look like
you yeah but that's my life story of
being like a minority we always have to
you think anybody's look like me no you
think I ever read a script that's a days
do you think I ever read one script that
said and the the redhead the Red Hawk
and some redheaded boy friend Watson now
I got I got just as much uh flak in
terms of like finding out where I belong
role wise in the business that any other
minority has and they'll fight me on
that tooth and nail but like that's the
truth I don't look like a normal white
guy so when they're like you're just a
white do
it's like yeah but I don't look like
they don't this is not what they look
like so to them I don't look like almost
any of the roles except for like
redheads for ever in film were dorks
so there was like um what was the kids
[ __ ] named she with an S I keep going
not Stifler but us Sherman who was that
I can't remember anyway every
representation PI know yeah wasn't that
wasn't it Sherman the shermanator or
some [ __ ] oh but it's always been losers
dorks they've never made us look cool
ever ever ever
until Archie and that mother [ __ ] kid
isn't even a redhead they dyed his [ __ ]
ass hair that was a cart that was a
comic book
yeah but they turn into a TV show but
they didn't cast a Rhetta they cast a
[ __ ] regular kid who died he serves
[ __ ] I'm so mad at them I tweeted it
the CW I was like you guys are trash I
put my [ __ ] people out on the street
man we're trying to eat no but every
time problem child remember that movie
yeah yeah any red head representation on
film and television you were an a total
[ __ ] nerd or you were like a little
weirdo a creep a gross like you know I
did never do such a there was such a
redhead backlash there's a stigma
against agnya and felt that all your
life all my life what do you mean yeah
that people make worthy only and I can't
say minority cuz people get mad at me
for saying it but we're the only honest
like subcategory of white mm-hmm that
like people can make fun of and it's all
okay
you like the Asians of white no but no
one can say anything do you mean like
yeah yeah yeah in the revolution of
what's happening right now for race and
culture and class and like in the
texture of what you can and cannot say
if you try to jump in but they're just
like tone it down straight white male is
it fun yeah people still think like it's
funny to crack jokes about redheads and
we have no no no leg to stand on like
even if we're like yeah we don't like
that that's kind of it's rude and
fucked-up and annoying like I don't like
when people just like mock my red hair
you're like this is so cheap and shitty
yeah but socially it's okay yeah well
because in the group we act cause in the
grand scheme of things they're probably
thinking like you know you're you're
still able to rent an apartment nobody's
saying you know we don't want allow red
right exactly exactly it's not I'm not
having the trouble that minorities have
I'm saying
we we have to like just ex
the fact that like people can publicly
mock redhead cold and make fun of
redheads right and it's like oh well I
guess it is what it is that's just it's
a part of like I guess people can just
make fun of redhead like if I go into a
store and somebody cracks a joke about
it like if the cashier or something is
like an older woman you know and she's
like oh god that's bright as the Sun you
know it's like I have to be nice yeah
you can't come back I came in like yeah
[ __ ] you're 65 working at this [ __ ]
CVS pack up my [ __ ] you know I'm not
allowed to be mean about how that annoys
me but that would annoy anybody with
anything like but other people could be
like I could snap back I can't snap back
on it thats interesting then I look as
mean as they think I am yeah I never I
never I never thought of them at it like
that I guess no one would know yeah it's
not a boohoo thing it's not like oh poor
me or poor reddit but it's it's annoying
when people crack jokes about red hair
cuz it gets old but that's probably
what's also annoying about it too that
you that all it annoys you and you can't
make a big deal about how much is it
annoys you that's [ __ ] it yeah
what's the thing people mock use the
most for oh just pick something dude
it's this annoying but what's the what's
the one thing that you're like when they
do it it drives me [ __ ] insane well
when I was a kid he used to be about
having a big nose so just got like I
would just wait for it I'd be a new
school you know and I just what happened
you got a big nose oh my god I know it
just would drive me bananas it just
wouldn't fight over word glasses you
know it wasn't it wasn't to that point I
like getting into fights but it just
annoyed me and I didn't it
all the way up to high school it was it
was all man you don't even know I
remember and my I did not then what
would this what would annoy me okay
because people who ever had a big nose
like famous figures I became those
people all the time so like when that
[ __ ] Humpty dance came out yeah you
gotta embrace that he's light-skinned it
was just like it was a nightmare
that was a nightmare year okay you know
everybody's here you go to the Burger
King bathroom you know me I was like huh
so that was I got freaky in there by the
way that was a good learner at least you
got laid your hero's got laid they were
like okay Opie Taylor you got Pippi
longstockings dog look at let's talk
about my heroes let's talk about the
red-headed representation in Ron Howard
okay okay wait wait wait let's go one by
one Ron Howard
famous rich director on the top five
directors went as a kid okay all I heard
as a kid was Opie Taylor he was at Posey
and you got he was wrong he was Richie
Cunningham it was a square it was a dork
he was a [ __ ] nerd who did you want
to be I didn't want to be anybody I
didn't want to be always compared to a
redheaded guy on TV I meet okay what I'm
saying so that's yours okay you had that
one how about Alf how about that hey I
look closer now than you do by the way
but I'm just saying this color is much
closer that I know well that was like it
was Turkey and you should go as alpha
next Halloween no no we we should go as
like people from here but who look like
from the Alf plan planet yeah we're from
elves planet but I'm like Chris D'Elia
yeah no yeah like okay so Alf that so
but for me it was names it's also like
fire crotch it I got it this day there
are some like dumb adults who like I
don't have you know like you meet these
people to have like zero sense of humor
right and you're like oh they're just
dumb and that's all they know is like
the common dumb thing if they think get
er done is a hysterical phrase you know
I mean like they'll say it at like you
know they checking out a Home Depot
yeah he's like well good luck with that
project is I'm gonna get order they both
laugh cuz they're [ __ ] stupid that's
the same guy who thinks fire-crotch as a
hist is hysterical like they think
that's funny like a guy said that to me
he was like hey what's up fire crotch go
ahead
drawing because all the other artists
that are gonna watch it yeah and I'll
make a fire crotch picture of you see
that's funny yeah that's fun love like
when dumb people think those phrases are
funny it's so hack to me it's like a
hack you're like a hack adults fire
crotch yeah Pippi Longstocking yeah well
you wanted it you wanted a pump Pippi
you want to pull those pigtails with her
with her scrub and shoes on you know she
just got done cleaning yeah it was
always someone and lame or stupid or
annoying or yeah it was always someone
annoying he was always trash people that
had a but when I was a kid at my first
school in Chicago all the black kids
would call me Opie but it was like
almost a term of endearment more black
people that said it were like what's up
Opie but it was like fun for them it was
less like when somebody tried to fight
me when I was a kid when people made fun
of me it was out of like anger like they
were like [ __ ] you this real-life
cartoon well I mean for me it's like
well kid look cuz I right now well I
can't stand see I don't mind a good joke
yeah sure oh good we love good joke your
love [ __ ] on things but the thing
that I hate the most though right now
yes it's somewhat like somebody ODM you
know get mad and they'll be like a fat
boy or you know they just say they just
use fat but doesn't that go away for you
that see that to me feels like that's
just not even us I know but it's like to
me I just go it's lazy it's like that's
what I don't like about I'm like really
yeah is if is if I'm gonna be like this
what I'm broaden live in a skinny life
for so long now it's like you get some
[ __ ] you know and then like Bobby
doesn't help with like you know well
yeah so we always joke about Star Wars
yeah so I always I always said you know
he looked like Yoda and he calls me fat
Lando
so like Lando Calrissian was a you know
Billy Dee Williams care I know he was a
scene in like Star Wars I'm well
I'm well-adjusted as an adult I know
cultural zeitgeist I understand oh
excuse me
that's C by the way that's why I don't
watch that [ __ ] I'm smart enough to
culturally get it so I'm okay like look
look like like do I know um
do I know who uh uh all the Star Wars
characters are yeah Star Trek I can't
name you [ __ ] I know who Harry Potter
know who Hermione I know the cast we
have to know Ron Weasley guys are
another garbage ass character Ron was
not a garbage character yes he was not
he was really a row he was Harry side
[ __ ] well he's he can't be the main
chick he's ready now imma start calling
you fat in this model
III think I think I think people think
it's like Europe gonna be insecure
offended by it but it's more just you're
like annoyed at how late lazy people I
just want it to be funny
scar but people are just mad you know
they just like just I love putting I
love screenshotting those things and
just putting on good look at this guy
said like right you do that cuz you want
your fans to hit them no no no I don't I
don't want to give them that attention
oh so it's even better because I got the
name yeah cuz then they see it and they
they're not getting the attention that
they wanted people are still like you
know they can see what people say but I
don't know I just I just think that kind
of stuffs lazy look I'm just so yeah at
this point right now I'm so used to it
like it's just like it's like it's just
it's just like whatever you know I'm
working on it for myself
I don't mind when people are like yo man
you're fat because what I hear is hey
man you should get healthier you you
should probably be in better shape you
want to live longer that kind of stuff
that's not what I heard that's what did
you hear when somebody says you're fat
to you I hear they are filling an
emotional hole by taking out something
on you that really bothers them maybe
not that they're fat but something bugs
the [ __ ] out of them in so they're
physical insecurity is easy to call you
fat because whatever it is about them
that's physically not cool it's easy to
go well I'm not fat in their brain they
feel better about
going well what I do is like I don't
care about I don't care about them
enough to like care about their psyche
right I agree with that too I've heard
this too but I just go III hear
something that someone says and I go mmm
if I don't want anyone to say that about
me again what should i do what should i
what does that really mean to me and I
just be like okay yeah because first of
all being fat because everybody feels
fat at certain point but what we're
really saying is we want to look good
naked yeah I want to you want to feel
better when I do make that yeah you will
be sexy naked that's all that it really
Mir cuz you know your girl says like
you're just like what the [ __ ] you talk
about you're not fat at all but when
they're looking in the mirror before
they get in the shower they're seeing
things that we don't see friends that
insecurity so right no so but anyways
cuz I'm all about talking about like I
think that this whole like softening of
America is like you know that's part of
it I think it's all that we were lying
to people about but like body body
shaming and or you know all that stuff I
think it's all it's all ridiculous and
the real points are getting lost in all
that liberal nonsense you saying because
people should people you think people
should wag the finger a little bit more
at at heavy-heavy culture or fat
promoted culture yeah this fad promoting
is like to me so ridiculous I mean cuz
it's cuz it's like it should be cut in
half because one side of it is hey you
should be healthier you know you're not
you know this is the type like obesity
is real like obesity is that kill very
real it's a killer yeah you know what I
mean so so you have that part of it and
the other part of it is just like being
nicer to each other right that's that so
in their conflating the two you know
kind of like it's kind of like can't you
say can't you say yeah you I've told you
I talk about this like there was a girl
there the New York Times put out an
article that said in Times Square they
were putting up Calvin Klein was only
gonna use plus-size models for their
underwear campaigns right and they put
up this picture of this heavy girl very
heavy you know very and all I wrote was
i retweeted it
and I wrote that's one way to sell more
fabric that's just a funny tweet
I didn't say [ __ ] fat people well there
was a lot of unwritten it so who's my
under trust ball stop bullshitting okay
no no you're not a really nice way to
call this big [ __ ] big no I found a way
I found a way to mock all of it
brilliant that repulsion yes thanks it
hear that right you weren't doing what
you were doing I wasn't saying but I
wasn't saying [ __ ] fat people I was
saying if you want to be real if I
really want to get deep on you like
psychologically what I was saying is
this is another corporate game that
they're playing to pretend like they're
woke and aware like they care about big
people you know they just want to feel
like they're involved in social issues
so that's that was my joke is like
truthfully I'm being serious like
psychologically my joke wasn't about her
being fat as much as it is like well
that's their trick to sell more clothes
that's me you know I mean like literally
two layer joke of being like it's that's
something there's a lot of late it's
them saying it's them truly saying hey
we are in - we're it were a part of the
it's [ __ ] that I'm calling out
Calvin Klein on their [ __ ] but so
yes and the subtext below that is you're
using big models not because you like
them or you care about them using them
because you think that's the cool thing
to do it's in it's ridiculous but how
often do you work out in a week if I'm
busy
it found busy like I am now like if I'm
shooting and doing stuff two to three
days a week if I'm not busy five or six
okay this is my point
yeah okay you're in great shape the fact
that you're even aware of it like that
is the point it's part of your life part
is part of who you are especially you
have a standard that you've set for
yourself and you have to work at it
yeah it sucks so hey us fat asses out
here are not doing that right this is
the thing that pisses me off this whole
like you know body shaming and this you
know promoting body positivity you
to be body-positive because you don't
want to workout don't tell me about this
train let me be positive about the the I
want to stay it like this right you know
right and I can speak on this because I
know how I wanted to work out before you
got here but I've made excuses
well how many how many days a week do
you work out [ __ ] I don't and
that's the thing but you did for a while
you were going out was yeah I was saying
I was but I haven't then then I started
going on the road and what I realized is
I had to add something else cuz I was
using that as an excuse
well you don't wanna run you know I
workout him when I go boxing no I have
to get some [ __ ] where I wake up I do
sit-ups and push-ups and go to the
treadmill and do get my cardio in this
is the kind of thing we should be
promoting to people I mean and what I
can't stand is like the this culture
which is mostly coming from the left
unfortunately yeah I'm a self-hating
liberal you know it means hang you know
so the left is like you know they think
obesity you have a joke about this
obesity is liberals global warming the
global warming is liberals global
warming cuz like they don't think it's
real right you know they just like they
want even though ninety-nine percent of
scientists say obesity first of all more
people are gonna know you're gonna know
more people they die from obesity than
global warming okay that's a [ __ ]
fact okay cuz obesity leads to heart
disease is there's so many things that
it leads you somewhere and we're sitting
here active trying to tell people no
this is okay I'm like I'm oh and I'm
just a harsh dude I'm okay with being
like big [ __ ] please you know I'm just
okay with that no okay
being like [ __ ] you I disagree here's it
but it's battled in closing in the same
way though I do understand that what is
that's why I'm saying it's twofold it's
like let's talk about getting healthier
and being healthy and being the best
version of ourselves right and then the
other side of it is like how we talk
about it is what they're talking about
right you know that that's what they're
trying to get rid of body positivity
really should just mean hey be nice to
people don't just call someone a fatass
yes say hey you know I know you know
you're a fat ass but maybe you could you
know what I'm trying to say yeah say it
it's just layers more nuanced than we're
giving it well it's just a great it's
just too great look look and I think I
might be a little bit slighted left of
where you're coming from in terms of
like I understand what what
body-positive is for it's to make young
women not feel insecure about what's
been thrown in their face their whole
[ __ ] lives like I'll be real about
that [ __ ] like the whole lives the end
immediate look at that photo right up
there of uma Thurman
no that's she saw that [ __ ] is so
[ __ ] skinny in that movie and like
that is the standard of living of what
we see in photographs and media it's
always always super skinny but by the
way yeah that is Harry Potter what do
you mean that's not what didn't we talk
are you talking about that's pulp
fiction no no that is equivalent to
Harry Potter I don't watch TV and movies
yeah to look at ugly people I understand
why I'm always like this 7th or 8th lead
okay because I'm the friend we don't
watch Hollywood so but I just I granted
I agree with you I know what you're
saying but it doesn't but but wit but
people do with you people of all shades
and colors and sizes need to be
represented but do they yeah yeah yeah
yeah here's wonder whether represented
at the DMV if you want real [ __ ] what
I'm trying to say is well represented in
real life we all just go out in real
life and you go oh look at this ten fat
people over here nice to see somebody
who's big on TV for for bigger this is
mostly for women by the way yeah men
have a different perspective on not that
men aren't it's just that bigger guys on
television tend to be still amplified in
a positive way their wife will be hard
what's a guy what's his name what's
wrong with the Mike and Molly we know
him oh I just talked to him yesterday I
love Billy yeah and Billy is on another
show so they barely know but Billy Billy
you live here
is fighting diabetes I knows what I'm
saying is like these are issues they
talk about on TV they talk about their
weight cuz they go this is real America
[ __ ] that's actually more real American
[ __ ] than 2 broke girls to hot ass
[ __ ] that are owning a bakery is
about like no so that version is more
realistic to me that needs to be a
little bit more represented because I
think people have a problem with it at
America because almost always women who
are big on TV are the butt of the joke
yeah yeah yeah he's just almost
exclusively yeah [ __ ] my dad calls
rebel Wilson he knows her at fat Amy
is her name because of that movie what
was a you know what that was a movie I
can't think that it wasn't government
assigned I know dog I'm saying but and
culturally though I know but but
cultural assignment is is heavy that's
where we get put yeah but she didn't you
know Louie CK didn't go to jail because
the government said he did wrong
socially Society put him in social
prison yeah I'm saying what we listened
to middle I think we're someplace in the
middle we need to get somewhere to the
man about our opinions oh I cuz I don't
disagree with you cuz I understand that
- I'm just saying like I'm just talking
about for me so I understand the the
what you're saying and why we need it
I'm just saying for me I don't look I
don't need that just you don't care I
don't care okay I feel that because
because because I'm like I'm like okay
this I need an escape from reality
I want my CSI agent hot I want a hot
blonde realize it's like when I was
watching I remember looking at Fantastic
Four which you never would have seen
here but Jessica Alba's a scientist
right and I'm in my mind I'm like if in
that world Jessica Alba is a scientist
what are the ugly chicks don't they're
homeless they're all homeless they have
no
yeah not to say that there are beautiful
scientists there are we're just joking
what does this say about the culture in
general this is some [ __ ] if we want to
go deep mm-hmm
when there is a girl who is very
good-looking uh-huh it's almost harder
for them to get into a job like that
yeah because people go what are you
doing here you too hot you know what I
mean I know it's crazy like they can't
even go some hawker I know this is like
that's like a hot problems but like it's
like you're redhead problem Bobby Lena's
podcast comes out in January 2020 never
it'll never catch you can't even get him
on the phone I did I got a phone last
night [ __ ]
he just came back he was I called him
last night he didn't answer
see this is [ __ ] you know he's all
over the place right now here I think
he's finally found his footing after his
parents yeah I know he's doing he's
going through some [ __ ] we both love him
like you know about parents [ __ ] you
know about troubles with [ __ ] with
family so I think what I think Pete
people think we're always having a good
time it's like not always [ __ ]
sometimes we're going through people
think like we don't have like I hate
when somebody comments online about
something about like D'Elia or like one
of the most successful comics you know
yeah I know like boohoo like cry in your
mansion and you're like they will
because they still cry just get rich
like people get hurt just because they
do work because you don't have money
problems a debt like or all that money
solves all of you that Bobby it's easier
to do it might be easier to deal with in
a way some problems but but like but
once you're in that world it's like it
doesn't you're not even thinking about
what it is to not be in that world
that's just great extra problem all
right
that's like I've always said I've always
said the phrase when someone who says I
would never buy a Ferrari I remember
somebody said that to me they were like
look at the guy was driving a no we got
well he's driving a Lamborghini SUV you
know those Larry Jesus yeah and somebody
goes I would never fight even if I had
all the money in the world I said but
you don't so you don't know what that's
like do you don't know like like I'm
just saying I'm not saying I would but
I'm not saying I wouldn't cuz I don't
know I don't have [ __ ] Lamborghini
much yeah those people live in a
different life so it's the first of all
Lamborghini money ain't even when
have Lamborghini money you're not even
thinking about how much money the
Lamborghini cost no you just you got
Lamborghini money that's like I was
talking about that literally on the way
here about Bill Gates I watched a
documentary about the bill get did you
watch that [ __ ] no I haven't seen it
yeah it's so good watch that [ __ ] but I
was thinking about like how he gets
around you know cuz I'm like here's the
guy who's like super conscious of
everything and he you know he's probably
secretly a monster well that this look
you know like I strata B they had to had
him in his Benz and I was like it's an
s550 and you know I know cars I love
cars and I was like it could be the the
e-version it could be the electric
version or the hybrid version but I was
still like all these guys they still
have their things that even though
they're conscious they'll never let go
do you know I'm saying like you still
has their conscious but they not flying
prime coach you know he'll mean coach
you know speaking of which you know who
I saw flying coach that was wild was
sitting in regular seats who you know
that look I was flying from here la - um
what a [ __ ] that I just go dude what did
I go was I Cleveland Detroit where did I
go I mean Cleveland Cleveland yeah
whatever um the Gretta soon bird girl
the climate girl oh really [ __ ] sang
coach well yeah well good for her I'm
surprised I was like for sure somebody
paid for this girl to be in first class
when I saw her no but she probably she
that's the kind of chick they can't be
in first class why they have to know
because she's cuz people gonna talk to
her in coach yeah but you know first of
all let's be real about something huh
domestic first class is just fancy coach
let's not act like domestic first class
is like really first class it's just
nice cuz you like Delta United in those
things don't [ __ ] ain't first class just
it's just big ass coach seats say guys
coach seats with you but only two seats
but I'm just saying that's like regular
people get upgraded there's still
riffraff up there today they do I know
bill bird talks about that he has a joke
about that
he's like after you've gone through all
the light you know it's like diamond
medallion members gold platinum members
you're like you see how many [ __ ]
layers are there now before Zone one
getting there by the time you get on
you're like how these people gonna do
that's United dude United
fly united by but anyway the point is I
know what you're saying like you know
they people think we don't have any
problems and people think we don't we
were worried by the weight of emotion
but the guy saw Bill Gates uh this was
years ago he was building some house and
it was like a hundred and fifty million
dollars the famous but it was like you
know it was like like the art was like
all digital and whoever walked in the
room they knew who it was like yes
normal don't know you not woke [ __ ] you
ain't woke what would you do that's what
we're saying that what would you do with
that kind of money I would do that cuz
right now look at me right now you right
now sitting here today I give you a
check I'm a Dubai Sultan I give you a
check for two hundred million dollars
and I say is one stipulation I think
about this all the time
uh-huh you have to leave entertainment
you can't do this anymore
no more stand-up no more film I'm out
you know he doesn't really love it I was
a bit in your face as I took the fake
you gave you money cuz I got spit in
your face money he closes the account
when you no no IIIi don't yeah [ __ ] it
I'm out what's the first money buy with
all that money I don't know I just know
I would collect call a lot of people
what do you mean I would collect call
people hi this is a collect call from
Eric do you accept the charges
why then I'd be like I'm out I won you
collect call people cuz you got so much
money yeah you keep your money you don't
keep you don't keep your money by
spending this [ __ ] first of all you know
what's funny two hundred million dollars
ain't a lot of money you're bananas it's
not [ __ ] you much it's absurd [ __ ] you
money it's not two hundred million
dollars is not [ __ ] you money it's not
Bill Gates money about having two
hundred million dollars you talking
about what almost irresponsible insane
humans of all time hey what I'm saying
is most people are irresponsible insane
when you look at how would you seen that
thing about people that win the lottery
most of them go broke
I know because they were broke in the
first place he's not broke people don't
know
handle money yes normal so that's why
I'm saying you're not normal and I knew
already make a living so I know what
kind of money is real [ __ ] you money
[ __ ] you money is over a hundred million
is [ __ ] you money maybe some of them
some of your richest friends have just
about that kind of money and no the
richest people we know yeah but check it
out when you when you have this kind of
money like us like you have access to it
okay you know if you're gonna like you
know if you have a 20 million dollar
house that costs money to maintain yeah
cause that's why all those people always
end up selling their houses and stuff
that never keep them what's his name uh
Ed McMahon from a lot of the fans won't
know who the [ __ ] that is but Ed McMahon
from that from the tonight know that
Johnny Johnny Carson's right-hand man
yeah um Ed's house was like foreclosed
upon and the latter years of his life up
in the Sunset Hills because he'd never
paid his mortgage and then you have the
taxes a lot of mime saying this like it
is you have a hundred but if I got a two
hundred million dollars if I had a
hundred man and I lived the same yeah
that's my point that's Google but I
wouldn't live the same nobody would
that's not true I would if I got a two
hundred million dollar check right now
you wouldn't you wouldn't change your
life at all the only thing I would
change is I would travel way [ __ ] I
would that's all I would do
I probably sell my house for real I
probably sell the house so I didn't have
possessions uh-huh dude I I have wet
dreams about this I would I want to sell
everything so bad and then just travel
and live and figure it out I want to
live that's my dream I have a buddy like
I literally have a buddy that does just
this he has nothing and he just goes
that's what he does anytime he comes
into town here's like a new camper that
he bought like and it's not like a new
brick it's like one of those like he had
to fix it up and then when he's done
with it he sells it you know in his
Instagram he's always in like I'm in
Dubai I'm in Bali I'm in like you've
done these little weird places I went to
I went to college of the kid he's just
and he's like he's like younger than us
yeah you know he's like he he comes from
I'm gonna tell you where this family
comes from but I'm like and he's
good-looking too right very good
so all his Instagram is like it's like I
know this guy's just bad [ __ ] on I
don't know you're
but I know my guy you don't I mean this
[ __ ] did you wear jewelry no he
doesn't he's not one of these ladies a
minimalist okay okay no but I mean like
is he like a hippie kind of casual I
mean like he's like asking about
diamonds that he made himself and some
Native American dude gave him fabric
right where somewhere she the tail is me
you know I mean it's like it's really in
yeah this dude that dude that dude I
know that dude i but that's my dream
sell all my [ __ ] sell everything and
leave and just bounce
I would love to bounce for a decade so
you know what I want to do I want to
live on a I want to live on a fancy
cruise ship for six months you love that
shy how many cruises you been on now
I've been on a lot of cruises but I'm
talking about this particular type of
cruise is it kind of cruise at like NBA
players live on the ball yeah I'm
talking about one of those like you know
I mean it's not a cruise it's not a
cruise it's not a cruise yes it's a
big-ass fancy boat and they might be
like okay we're going to the South of
France
that's yes those are yachts a super
yacht nekoma super yacht yeah yeah like
the dude that used to was a dude that
used to maybe he was the owner of the
heat at one point and he had the super
yachts yeah like three super yachts down
in Miami Oh what I was I got it because
he owned car it wasn't he is that the
Carnival Cruise that same guy
yeah and he had these super yachts and
they and it was it was literally like
they said three Beverly Hills mansions
on a boat that's how big they were but
dude this is what I'm saying though
about [ __ ] this what I'm saying about
like I get what you're saying at a
certain level anyone can achieve [ __ ]
you money it doesn't have to be because
it's just where their level is yeah but
what I'm talking about is when you can
own an NBA team and it's just a hobby
yeah - [ __ ] you - [ __ ] you mom see
that's a difference see I say that's
above [ __ ] you money I say that's now I
think you're Illuminati money you're
part of the system up there when you're
that rich and famous you've got to be a
part of this of the thing you think you
know you think so you think Warren
Buffett Bill Gates 100% these people are
all in a club together I bet my [ __ ]
hears I'll give you a small example
give you a smaller example we when we're
on Tex chains right with upper echelon
comedians or famous people or don't
quote how exclusive are they I know
extremely right you would never let in
somebody else and you don't talk about
it and it's a thing right that's at our
level of nothing nobody like when you go
up and up and up you know they're all
looped into a game to go how can we kind
of retain this wealth and keep in our
little circle that's how they do it
they're like you my kids go work for
your family you help out this they all
go to some exclusive high school you
like you like Game of Thrones anybody
who likes Game of Thrones should be into
the idea of the Illuminati because
that's all that's all royalty was that's
all like monarchy was all about how
could we keep all this [ __ ] money and
fame in this little circle of ours how
can we be above the peasants and then
keep inner twenty so the the what's old
money to this I'm saying is a family
sends over the daughter to get [ __ ] by
the next Prince they're trying to keep
it in the you know I mean they're like
our families are linked now [ __ ] I
didn't grow up with any of that [ __ ] so
that's it that's why I don't like that
stuff to me fantasy means like wealth
well you know also also like being a
comic cuz you got to be rich to dream by
the way I know people don't the poor
people don't have time to dream well
they can dream but they just feels like
it always feels like a pipe dream that's
what I mean but like being a comic
though something I you we learned coming
up is like we just learn how to be
frugal yeah you don't have a choice yeah
we just learned how to like how much
[ __ ] do you save that you don't even say
I do this computer work it does and I
only keep it because I have a unlicensed
copy of Photoshop on it so dumb but that
literally is the reason why I kept
rollin I have so many unlicensed copies
of things my wife's mom used to work for
the school system so I would get
Microsoft oral program I want it you
know what's funny now they're all
unregistered and it keeps saying like
please register a continue and I'm like
you know you know what's funny I just
had the update of the new the new Mac
update yeah you you have to actually now
by Microsoft Word I won't update check
it out I've been using Microsoft
were for free for so long my whole life
that I just said [ __ ] it I bought it you
know I was like Microsoft they should
give that to us for fridges I bought it
how much was it it's like it's just now
that everything's a subscription now but
they don't you can't buy any software
anymore so you use it you monthly
monthly it's like you use of license it
for a year
what is the license for you I forgot it
was like $99 or something like that
I've been using it for free for some
thieves everybody deserves to make money
no but they Microsoft made tons of money
I know they already made all the money
yeah give it to us I've been using that
for I think about that you've been doing
something for free your whole life and
then now they want to charge you for it
that's crazy
no that's what nobody but but I've been
using it for free illegally Wow really
not really because they would give it
away for a long time yeah like remember
how a o L they would give it to all
youth an hours for free yeah they were
just using that as a marketing tool
promotion to be like this really is for
free
no one ever paid for a o L right this is
a scam Microsoft has a [ __ ] skin to
hold the whole system's a scam
nothing it's you know it's a scam this
is a good great example of a scam
college scholarship scam what a scam
scam because it would be like it would
be like you know you you you already own
the building the teachers are already
there okay you have a room for the 30
people you're saying to some kid you're
gonna be number 31
oh and that costs $50,000 [ __ ] it costs
you absolutely nothing you just letting
them come into a classroom that these
other people are already paying for by
the way it would only cost you something
if if each heads if each head in that
room if their tuition was part of a
financial system but instead these
schools are surplus they have hemp they
they have so much they make so much
[ __ ] money yeah that it's not like
Eve every head matter it's not a
Community College different stories yeah
yes every head matters to keep those
schools running they need they need
enrollment government money too right
that's an enrollment they need state
funds dude these are the [ __ ]
universities they get hundreds of
millions of dollars from [ __ ] alumni
from all these other things they're they
have so much they have such a surplus of
money they're like we're gonna rebuild
wing wing beast they don't have so much
[ __ ] money so when it's at a big
college level I I agree it's scam
[ __ ] which is why pay to play I'm
in super-supportive we're a pay-to-play
state and I'm down yeah you're gonna use
my name in my likeness cuz let me tell
you something if these KITT if you're
selling their [ __ ] jerseys mine if
you want to sell a team jersey selling
them with their names on it but now
they're gonna be able to that's what I'm
saying because they couldn't for yours
yeah they sell their number yes I'm
saying which is equivalent it's the same
but if you're gonna sell a team jersey
without my name or number fine if it's
Stanford and you're just selling a
Stanford Jersey okay I get that but when
you start selling these kids likenesses
and and under the under the guise of
well that's a part of your part of a
school you're a part of a system and we
let you go over here for free [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
because people go to see those games
people go to buy those jerseys a lotta
money cuz of millions yeah because I'm
the runningback that they know well I
think it's a good thing but I think that
I think the money should be put into a
trust you know with an allowance in
terms of life for them to like you know
they do there's a financial system no no
but I'm saying like now I'm saying this
new system that's about to happen
no that's we're gonna do they're gonna
give them their it is put into a program
they're not just given checks yeah yes
you're put into a program so it's
allocated towards certain things right
especially if they're [ __ ] seventeen
if you get in a school and you're a
freshman a first year and if you're this
blowout guy yeah they can't just touch
the money right away yeah okay that's
good then yeah they're I mean who knows
how it's gonna work out when it goes cuz
you bureaucracies a nightmare [ __ ]
everything up but here's what's really
gonna happen people are gonna be putting
more money into those accounts on the
side you want to talk about college was
shady before with outside don'ts what
I'm saying no no they're just gonna be
like I own a dealership and I'm gonna
put your face you know on the outside of
my you know Hyundai dealership do their
own and here's a hundred thousand
dollars but it's also gonna be under the
guise of that but it's also gonna be
like hey during pay-to-play if you come
play at if you come play at Alabama you
know I got a lot of weight in Alabama so
for pay to play if they become a pay to
play state these sponsors are donors
they're gonna already slide them money
under the guise of yeah this is for pay
to play this is just a sponsorship thing
I think it's a look I think it's a good
thing because they should be taught
money on an early age cuz otherwise you
listen to these guys Chris Paul just did
an interview about it he said his first
check blew his [ __ ] brain he didn't
know what to do so
you get to the NBA and you get a big
check don't I bet you get scared I bet
you get a little scared
so in college they should be given a
comedy club check I was like the first
check you got didn't it make you know I
did a TV show yes my first check I
bought my parents one of those eye and
iMac hmm I shouldn't have that's
expensive yeah but I got I thought wow I
can finally do some with money so when
you don't teach people about money I
think they need to scale them in early
so in college they should be given a
little bit of money scale it in and by
the time they get to the pros I don't
know though then you get it most of them
won't get to the pros that's my point
though that's why they need money more
than anything yeah cuz otherwise a lot
of these [ __ ] go to school they
get out there but now there's a chance
like those games like the NCAA games in
the video games now everybody that's on
the on the roster is gonna get money
should yeah yeah cuz if [ __ ] EA Sports
is getting Bank it's in the game yeah is
it is it in the game dudes in the bank
that's what you EA sports it's in the
bag we took your [ __ ] money not yours
yeah it's in our bank doing that keep
doing the job that we make you do for
free I've thought about you the other
day because I was at the Apple Store you
think about me all the time
sometimes yeah what a dick face you are
so I was at expelliarmus
hey you don't touch another man's wand
this is our version of rush hour yeah so
I was at the Apple Store mm-hmm
and I'm wait you know you have to wait
in the queue for them to help you you're
gonna dress me up you're gonna get me
started you know how mad I get guys so
annoying I'm a no wait two people walk
over mm-hmm one guys get to Apple and
then regular guy the regular guy says
hey um hi I'm just I'm his translator I
was like what time I hold on one of the
men had an Apple shirt on okay so I
worked at Apple and the other guys like
I miss translate I was it what now boy
he did the guy that worked at Apple was
deaf mmm I thought it was translation of
language barrier that was gonna make me
more mad I was like we hired this form
of my girl can't speak English
dude the thing I was like here's my
thing about it you think I don't know
where you're going
the dude was cool okay yeah all I'm
saying is let me know
like what I'm signing into the queue you
should be like we you know Helen Keller
is available are you cool with this that
could be like I could be like you know I
got time this is you know because it's
extra I need to get out of here
well now I have to deal with this you
know I have to deal with like you know
do what I do with cool though I think
everyone should be given a chance to do
yes
but but that but beads no you can't be
deaf and be in customer service word
just a lot of jobs he could do there's a
lot of [ __ ] you know not customary
should be he should be like doing the
customer service on the chat the chat
customers to earn you know people call
people and he's like hi I work at Apple
let me help you
he deserves the same pay but just can't
but in the store yeah come on
and there's another so now I'm like I
don't think it's myself like a blind car
salesman you're like I just I can't I
can't sorry I can't do what I'm things
myself the dude just talking yeah can
you just help me yeah he doesn't even
work for Apple
he wouldn't anyway though cuz it's part
of the thing right they're not allowed
to yeah yeah like I can't answer this
but I have to but you know what I told
the dude I was a comedian and I was
gonna talk about it oh so you've been
[ __ ] on him yeah somebody knows you
invite him what he won't be able to
bring his translator oh that's what the
guy's gonna be on have you ever done a
comedy show like that yes those are the
best yes man such a fun time yeah you
know I've had a few shows where and we
do always do the same thing honey how do
you say suck my [ __ ] by the way we all
know them we all know it wait you know
what I asked him this is so hilarious so
when the deaf guy comes over with a guy
my first thought was like wow this is so
woke yeah it's very he he I forgot what
the sign was but woke was like something
like this you bet it was like and I was
like well here's my problem with Apple
not only do you wait way too [ __ ]
long now I said to the guy I got so
frustrated last time I was in that store
I said when that I said that the
employee
said you know when that guy died this
place went to [ __ ] and his face was
stunned
I said yeah when he [ __ ] died this
place went to [ __ ] and it did let me
tell you something they haven't
reinvented this thing in forever it's
the same [ __ ] design for four or five
years now they haven't you manipulate it
used look what we remember your phone
down in the cabinet now the difference
of year to year to year was remarkable
in fact Android commercials make fun of
iPhone for looking the same for the past
five years yeah and by the way then they
copy their design which is also it's
like yeah there's only there's only a
certain number of designs limited amount
no no it's limitless dude they came up
with this in the first place we never
thought this was possible so no there is
no limit to what they're gonna make a
phone look like it's just apples become
so focused on ancillary products that
this is not the priority anymore Yeah
right so like air pods are massive now
they bought beats so now they weren't
all the beats property like the new
beats over the ears my boy used to work
for Apple he sent me those they're
[ __ ] phenomenal but it's like that's
their priority this thing is not this
doesn't matter to them anymore
this is movement this moving these units
it's kind of like it's supplementing
it's kind of like how a gas station
doesn't really make money on gas
yeah you know that like they barely make
money on drives like how does it go yeah
it doesn't make money on move yeah makes
money on concessions so it's like this
is popcorn to Apple it's like yeah we
like selling it but it's not gonna make
us the most [ __ ] money right there
iCloud services they're ancillary
products so when he died I think they
accepted the fact that this was
weighting them down and they were losing
money on certain phones they would come
out with a phone and lose money that's
why the [ __ ] mist Elevens are the see
remember the see the call well we had to
go away cuz they [ __ ] they ate [ __ ]
they couldn't sell any of them so I'm
just saying they've gone downhill to a
degree now where they don't they're not
innovative with those the lines are
longer I went to go buy my wife the
[ __ ] the new one they wouldn't let me
walk and buy it why can't I [ __ ] walk
in and get it and leave and the guy was
like you have to check into this thing
and wait and I want a byline gimme the
[ __ ] gimme the [ __ ] [ __ ] I give
you the money let me walk the [ __ ] out
of here I can set it up at the cloud at
home and they're like the guy goes well
a lot of people need help I go I am
electing Delta not in your help I
walk out with the phone right now
unlocked unsimplified house in Boston
there's an Apple store across from the
hotel Apple you know and I had I needed
I had a problem with my watch whatever
it is and it was like the line absurd
try to get help it's impossible you know
and then and what I can't stand is you
know what I do timeout real quick I
think they pay people to come hang out
and helpline so you [ __ ] off yeah dude
this is what I can't stand when I'm in
the helpline yeah I don't want to see
one [ __ ] with a Apple shirt on
[Laughter]
she's me Micah we got a whole [ __ ]
line you don't need to restock the cases
yeah dude I can't stay you're the same
cat put some hop to your step run run
run [ __ ] strolling through the Apple
store and there's a long like a baseball
coach like get out there let's go you're
the same guy that goes to a restaurant
and when they go it's like and you see
tables and you go you walk in the place
is empty
obviously nobody has a reservation in
this mother but you know what I do cuz
you know my level of impatience when I
walk in and that happens I go we're good
and I leave ya I leave and they can feel
it cuz they know I want them to know the
next time that somebody walks in that
there go we can accommodate ya just
figure its business I'm trying to just
give you money all I'm trying to do is
give you [ __ ] money my favorite thing
is when somebody goes we can fit you in
but we're gonna need this table back by
8:00 oh I'm like let me tell you
something I'm gonna I'm gonna do that
I'm gonna eat here and when that thing
that you need to show up at 8:00 comes
if it comes guess what holler at me yeah
yeah cuz guess what if I'm not done
daddy's not leaving
that's how it goes what the [ __ ] am I
gonna do oh I'm gonna get my plate yeah
I'm gonna go outside I'm gonna go to
valet okatee here now I don't play with
that [ __ ] but says customer service is
just gone to [ __ ] altogether it doesn't
exist because it because now the
Internet has has stolen the marketplace
so which is a good thing and a bad thing
but now that Amazon is everything now
people have to worry about I love Amazon
dude see you're the part of the problem
I'm sorry like the camera I needed a new
lens cap Amazon bro I just went on lens
care 59 tomorrow the [ __ ] was
here two more wrong I know you know and
just anything you need just go how do I
look you know you just get it i order my
groceries I just you know everything I'm
just all about it I know I love it but
also it's the devil it's the devil we
know it's gonna come back and bite us in
the ass like like it starts small right
it start small with like people stealing
packages but now then it's because now
it's gonna be it's just at this point to
me don't put the drones are coming in
now it should be outside your door but
here's why they know too much you know
here's then I don't like how people who
deliver now for Amazon it's you and it
can be anybody do that's why I want the
drones I'm with you on I don't want the
power want some Jewish majors so Josh
Martin you know what I can't stand when
they're like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah but let's
not even are like a building that you
have to like see for me it's scary and -
I walked out of the house and although
it was dope two dudes that were
installing cabinets in the new house
across the street
the dude goes Sena - no I think it's one
of my neighbors uh-huh I go what's up
man I turn it's these two kids two young
young men and he goes all Mary huge
[ __ ] fan I was like oh thanks man the
other guy goes do we love you bro and
who's I get a picture I was like I'm
leaving man he's like alright and then
they were hanging out doing work yeah
and another you do know where I live and
you break it to your house right under
whatever it was well it's orange you
know I mean if I would have been one
tone yeah we brought it back full circle
yeah see like IOP I was a great
now I just it's weird when people know
where you live cuz you're like I want
anonymity anonymity as much as anybody
any any fan that you have that watches
they don't want anybody else to know
where they live except for who you want
to know where you live it's not that
it's like I think I'm famous it's like
no no no I don't want people to know why
this do I was I was in his bed live
there I live in this building you know
it's like you know whatever a thousand
[ __ ] units and then somebody sees me
in the guys like oh [ __ ]
then he tweets guess who lives in my
building oh boy you know and I said I
tweeted back and I said and he probably
doesn't want people to know that yeah
yeah you know he got it he was like take
it down [ __ ] down dude that's why but
that's why seriously that's why a lot of
people don't live anywhere near LA yeah
that's why people that people that work
in the business a lot of them leave
because they're like I don't want to be
I don't wanna be accessible for people's
gossip you know man you ball in your
business but it's funny because like
even in my building right now so funny
and I'm sure the guy cuz I got this I'm
coming down and going to the parking lot
to my car and just like beautiful girl
and like this weird guy well that's like
would you say about my English yeah cool
talk to you at the meetings weird weird
guy hot girlfriend media meetings so I'm
talking to you [ __ ] and then
he's like take a picture and I'm like I
come on man it was kook as a girlfriend
was like stop being a weirdo the
girlfriend's never want to put up every
girl every dude that's like what's up
bro the girlfriends are always like who
the [ __ ] is that oh I have a great story
about her and can we leave Rogan says
that when he starts his shows yeah it's
very funny he's so self-aware we go we
did a [ __ ] arena in Cleveland he
opens the show by going
what's up Cleveland if it was I know
then he goes all right how many girls
are here because their boyfriend brought
them and then they cheer and he goes I'm
sorry
it's though cuz at least he knows that
there's a lot of
pros that are like regard ago she broken
in there like hell I don't know what is
who is that
a Seth Rogen Seth Rogen's Pam it's the
same thing when like they're like the
girls are like she only female fans yeah
she there's a lot of female fans like
it's like cuz I I know cuz I went way
back in a new boyfriend's get drugged to
those shows I feel like I feel like any
boyfriend as I hang on
no they just go cuz I remember I was
doing a show with her a long time ago
for a New Year's yeah and like as the
the what couples are walking out and the
girls are like oh thank you I'm sure
iliza shlesinger has a lot of I would I
don't know how many boyfriends husbands
yes but boyfriends because men are
[ __ ]
I feel like boyfriends like I'm not
going to that [ __ ] yeah but at a certain
point you you have to go when you've
done when you've got taking her to so
many look at me if she wanted to go to
some [ __ ] and I didn't want to go I was
on that going you know what unless I
know I unless unless it's something so
like like true like real to her that it
means a lot I would go to anything but
if it's on some [ __ ] that's like I kind
of want to do this and I it's like that
but I don't want to go gonna go [ __ ] no
like she wanted Alvin Ailey is a famous
choreographer she loves she's a dancer
she loved dance she want to go see Alvin
Ailey and I've bought the most expensive
tickets I cook as I know it means a lot
to her right I didn't give a [ __ ] about
that [ __ ] but I know that it means
something so it's worth it if it's just
something to do to something to do that
I'm like take a [ __ ] girlfriend go
get a grab a girlfriend go - I know by
the way last night but they want you but
they always want you to do [ __ ] I don't
want to do [ __ ] they just want you to be
there enjoying it understand and my
thing is like I'm not gonna enjoy this
that's the problem on your level right
I'll go but I think I'll be skipping
through the aisles and [ __ ] like here
why are we having fun you know why I
didn't want to do this in the first
place a mad at you about that yeah yeah
cycle so do I go this is why last night
he would have loved it last night I get
on stage and this woman probably in her
60s early sixties
two white women in the front left or
right older kind of like calm
hippie looking women yeah she goes like
this no [ __ ] I walk out on stage and I
see the one woman go to the other one
she goes like this so my assumption is
she's like who is this guy why were they
why they even clap who is this
[ __ ] I I say that I said what
did you just say to her I'm smiling what
did you say there and she goes and she
goes what what and I go you went like
this are you are you mega fun if you
don't know who I am cuz I was like it's
all good a lot of people don't know who
I am you're good and she was like no no
no I was saying you know another another
another male and I was like what
and she's like another guy it's a it's
just another ID like I go oh you'd like
it to be more and she goes diverse I go
oh okay okay yeah okay I guess
and I said everyone starts cracking the
[ __ ] up everyone's already dying
and I was like well you know I'd like
more white representation in
professional sports but you know I just
I guess that is the way it goes is the
way it goes and the crowd lost it and
you should've seen she was like so
[ __ ] mad at me but I was like lady I
didn't panic I just I just I can't I'm
just on the line I can't stand afford
the this you had a great joke and you
started that job I'm doing so good about
the pay scale right yes it doesn't make
any sense don't do the joke on here it
just doesn't make any sense this idea
that like see I believe that skill based
performance based results business and
which is what we do should slowly be
based off you know ability and like an
audience reaction and all this kind of
stuff so the reason that Dave
Chappelle's tickets are more expensive
than your and my tickets is audience
based there is a [ __ ] reason yes that
he can charge 120 if I charge 120 yes
come no one would show up yeah but like
for someone to get angry at why certain
people make a lot of money it's like
name is just even about the money so
much is it about like what it's like
what is this woman it's like like they
act like they act like people are
stopping women from right right yeah
they make it sound like the Comedy Store
cuts off women at the legs okay first of
all some of the funniest [ __ ] women
on planet earth are regulars at our
store and they're murderers whoever
should be there is there now [ __ ]
there and Sweeney Cummings rips that
room to shreds she's there when she's
there it's like saying why isn't there
more black or Asian or whatever on this
show first of all I think that it needs
to be addressed in this light there are
more white male performers in comedy
because it's a career that whites have
been in for a long time white males and
if I was an Asian parent I'm probably
gonna promote my kid to not get into a
clownish [ __ ] [ __ ] career because
I got he I work hard to get it immigrant
culture doesn't love when kids get into
[ __ ] entertainment didn't want me to
get into I mean my parents we're like I
guess if that's what you want to do but
like the idea that it's an uneven
distribution of stage time is not true
there just so happens to be a
significant a significant higher amount
of white men in this because that is the
history of it it doesn't mean that well
Mike there's no room for other my thing
is like I need I need people to stop
mning Hollywood to be the answer for you
know our cultural woes that's your
that's your hot thing you know it's like
yeah if you want do diversity let's
start with Congress right okay yeah sure
let's start like like she should be
going like when she's looking at like
the State of the Union address and they
they show that they show the Congress
that woman should be going like that -
like why there's so many white males -
right right so you start there let's
start with like the stuff that actually
means something yeah you know like I say
my joke like Charlie's Angels
I want these [ __ ] white okay
like I don't I didn't win anything
because you like making stuff you're
changing [ __ ] how many are the new
Charlie's Angels how many who are they
who's in it it's like you know
Christians do it with a little short
haircut now though I'm just saying like
those are the kind of things where they
think let's do it here and oh this is
gonna be the thing that's gonna like
change it's like no no let's just this
that's um let's worry about this 2020
election okay worry about something that
has a big
impact on our our car our culture as a
American institution likely worried
about what really is dripping down from
the top five the bottom is not as is
priority it shouldn't be as prioritize I
mean I've talked it's important like you
were talking about what fat people say
one of yours ended and I understand it
when you look at TV you look at heroes
you look at things it's like especially
fictional [ __ ] yeah it's like I don't
mind it's like like yeah spider-man
could be black Superman could be Asian
because they're not real yeah they could
be Asian people on Krypton and in an in
the same story could happen I hope you
know they could be Jewish they can be
whatever so you know it's like when
Samuel Jackson is playing George
Washington in a movie call me I think I
think I've had this conversation with my
buddy EP and we talked about how black
Hollywood which he works in black
Hollywood I don't want to name what he
does but like he's very embedded in
black Hollywood right and it's very
prominent in what he does and like we
talked about how it's interesting that
black that Hollywood wants more
representation of black culture but
they're doing it sometimes to a degree
that's very cheap like they cheap in
something and they're like they want
their version of oh well that's right
that's always what it is I know so now
they're pretending always pretending
like they're but it's been such [ __ ]
but even even like same thing with Jay I
talked about it on stage that's exactly
what to say I talk about it now on stage
they want their version of gay and they
say we want gay no they don't they want
hey oh my god and the suitcases are
unpair mean and they only hold hands
yeah they don't why don't want they
don't want to see real gay or no they
know but they also don't want like
masculine gay men do you notice that
that like I have I have a lot of gay
dude friends that are like they suck
dick and throw a football do you know I
mean like they'll knock you the [ __ ] out
and know
the show coming to Fox this season on
Fox he can Huck at 68 yards and he can
take it no I just think like I think
it's [ __ ] that Andrew Santino is
Opie the new years whoa whoa coping whoa
please take it
what's up will [ __ ] you up and also [ __ ]
you I think they don't like they want
their version of [ __ ] which i think is
cheap and sad and gross and every time
they put a gay character on TV as a non
gay guy I get annoyed that it's the same
archetype of gay guy it's like so
[ __ ] he always has to be over-the-top
he's gotta be black it's like are there
gay guys like that yeah okay guys dude
why do they always have to be that way
like there's plenty of gay friends that
I have that don't that aren't that or or
they try to overcompensate and make like
the black character is like a super
smart nerd computer tech yeah doc they
put Donald Glover why cuz you like stuff
yeah I think it's offensive to black
culture when when he says that black
nerd it's like what do you mean do you
mean cuz you enjoy him it's like things
like I think it's annoying when somebody
goes I'm a black nerd or I'm he oh he's
like a black nerd like Black History
Month but you have to like you know it's
gotta be justified what do you mean
there's plenty of smart black people
that's almost diminutive to black
culture to go I guess I'm just a black
nerd it's like our most black people not
supposed to be smart that's what that
says to me but he stood on that hill a
long time and I thought that was like
his when he was doing stand-up that
always bothered me
he was like does that swim see I'm here
for the black nerds I was like what what
you're saying is black that you think
you're smarter than most black people
isn't that what that says am I wrong
it's one translation that's how I feel
that's how I felt that I was again such
a shame was in by the way and what's
what happens what's wrong with you know
one of my problems with society right
now and in terms of how it deals with
you know things like podcasts and and
culture and and news and entertainment
and media is that people it's like when
you look at a definition of a word in
the dictionary it'll say it means this
and it also means this right right right
what [ __ ] normally do is they
only pick one yeah and they go it can't
mean anything else but this right and
then and then that's wrong right yeah
you know you can't just be like it only
means this it just means like okay
that's the part that you saw but as long
as you recognize that it means other
things sure then we would we would get
along better yeah you know no I mean yes
but you're talking about education so
good luck fine
look man I'm gonna sit here and talk
forever which is why we should have been
doing this from the first place
so we don't have to worry about having
guests so I'm gonna have maybe I just
have you on once a month we'll just yep
yep and I'm on yours and like yeah you
got a couple you got to come by I will
come on yours I don't know why we
haven't done it up to this point I think
you know what it is I think part of it
is like you remind me of my friend from
high school's name was in your mall
his name was Jamal Anderson we played
basketball together and we were good
friends but we were very competitive
yeah you know we had a thing that it was
like and I think with us is like we both
started this podcast you at the same
time we're on the same number of
episodes it's kind of like I don't want
the [ __ ] on yet let me build my
own [ __ ] I want to build it up yeah
we're looking at each other but it's
like you know it's like I I don't I like
that you know and you you are one of my
dearest friends it was it's good sweet
friendly competition yes yes yes and
sorry and I think we're gonna end up
doing is just gonna kick Bobby out of
the whole thing and it's just Bobby's
gonna end up just not not podcasting or
he's just gonna do a nude live video
casts on stage just mother I told him he
keeps showing his dick in city the city
he's gonna get me to he's still doing
naked [ __ ] on stage yeah but so is Eric
Andre
yeah but Eric but Eric I feel like Eric
well his dick is mad it's big I know
I said the reason Bobby it's weighted is
because his penis is funny yeah he's
Asian
but it's funny I said a funny penis is
non-threatening a big penis it can be
scared someone could someone can feel
scared so mr. Crowley what does he do
with that but a small penis people laugh
everybody laughs and a small penis it's
funny
and I think you'll be fine yeah as long
as he has like a buffer just don't go in
the crowd okay okay
yeah we'll see we'll see right but you
know what we're all but actually so this
is it guy look there's no beef yeah why
do people think it just was a fun thing
but people look you know what I love how
engaged people are in the narrative I
kind of sad to be kind of like dispelled
it or I should just let you leave and I
come back in here
[ __ ] dude I'm an attraction about you on
my podcast this week I'm just [ __ ] eat
you alive it was funny we both guest
hosted uh tiger belly I know ya Bobby
when Bobby was gone and then and then
and then now now they're switching
studios and so it's all gonna be
different I think I think they're
switching up all sorts of [ __ ] oh really
I haven't talked to my cameraman kalila
and it was great yeah people like you
know it she said she should have her
honest it's actually you know you know
so but anyways look we're gonna I don't
want keep talking keep going we've been
gone a long time
this is riffing with Griffin this is
Andrew Santino I have all of his
information on below please watch his
podcast whiskey ginger this is riffing
with Griffin and you know well you'll
see us on each other's podcasts in more
in the future and maybe come see us at
the store you'll see how we get along
exactly come to the comedy store what if
you're in LA he has toured that he's -
he's about to do a theater tour yeah so
look out for that that just shows you
2020 red riding tour the whiskey ginger
doing way better for him than Google
Griffin to do it for me that's not which
is [ __ ] ridiculous I do need to get
my Ferrari warmed up electric cars on my
min but anyways again once again Andrew
Santino thanks for watching guys and I
will take it dude thanks for coming on
pleased to drive it out to work I
appreciate that and anyways thanks again
I'll see you guys next week peace out